well brian the events in washington
today are really now
seared into the minds of american people
including how
law enforcement responded many saying
police didn't act fast enough to stop
the riot
oracle mana joining us now live with the
stark comparison
now being made orca
well denise some are comparing law
enforcement's reaction
to the storming of the u.s capitol today
with their response
to the black lives matter protests in
d.c just a few months ago
experts saying there are now some deep
questions that need to be asked
and answered it was horrific a dark day
in american history wednesday with a
violent mob of trump supporters
descending on the u.s capitol building
lawmakers including those in nevada's
congressional delegation
placed on lockdown to me this is more
than protesting
it was more than rioting this is violent
extremism for those on the ground one
thing was obvious
the police they were clearly overwhelmed
at the capitol
video shows law enforcement struggling
to control the crowd the national guard
only mobilized after the riders overran
the building
a stark contrast to these images from
the summer showing the national guard
already on the steps of the lincoln
memorial
during the largely peaceful black lives
matter protest
that raises the question why wouldn't
you do the exact same thing
for thousands of people on the right
unlv professor tyler perry says
historically there's a perceived threat
when minority groups protest
he adds the pro-police attitude of trump
supporters may also impact law
enforcement's actions
in this discourse have convinced the
police that a trump rally
is not going to turn violent because
they're there to support them
the question now is if things will
change today has proven that they don't
care
about law and order but as long as they
say it they will be treated differently
photos of today's events also filled
social media
the president of the naacp tweeting that
quote
armed terrorists stormed the u.s capitol
with little to no recourse
reporting live tonight orca mana 8 news
now